[Musique]
cher journal j'ai fait un rêve pas ouf
cette nuit tu imagines si martin luther
king avait dit ça oui oui
[Musique]
l'espace ton était très différent tous
marcher au ralenti
c'était un peu dimanche tous les jours
et puis alors on sautait en moins sur
deux comme ça sans raison
c'était comme dans la vraie vie sauf que
je rester au lit toute la journée ou
dans mon canapé ou dans mon fauteuil
pendant ce que j'avais à portée de main
parce que en mettant le nez dehors
je risquais de tuer des gens sans le
savoir et sans le vouloir sur tout alors
je faisais cramer tout ce que je
cuisinais pour ça ça peut être pas trop
d'habitude quand même par moments je
m'autorise à sortir dehors ont signé une
lettre que je redis j'ai moi même mais
uniquement pour acheter du papier
toilette
sauf que dans le rêve le papier toilette
c'était un peu comme le golden ticket
temps charlie et la chocolaterie
tu vois quand il est caché qu'on doit le
chercher partout il n'en existait que
cinq rouleaux dans le monde entier donc
plus personne ne faisait kaka alors
j'applaudis c'est à ma fenêtre à 20
heures précises tous les soirs sans
exception pour fêter la fin de la
journée mais ça m'émeut et sur mu et
cinq minutes et puis j'en avais les
larmes aux yeux voilà je critiquais ceux
qui partaient près de la mer et je
n'avais pas de linge sale à apporter à
la mienne parce que bell
vivez en pyjama et c'était pour tout le
monde comme ça je n'étais pas la seule
alors je me plaignais du temps non bien
sûr mais en réalité je finissais par y
prendre goût et puis alors tout d'un
coup comme sa sortie de nulle part
j'étais libéré de chez moi mais je
n'avais plus très envie de sortir
il s'est remis à faire beau et bah
j'avais plus tellement peur parce que il
y avait du papier toilette par tous et
bon c'était réglé cette histoire là et
là il ya un immense pigeons qui m'a
foncé dessus avec son bec pointu et au
moment de l'impact j'ai eu tellement
peur que ça m'a réveillé d'un coup c'est
vraiment bizarre les rêves parfois